un appel à l'unité c'est ce qu'a lancé
le président après un vote massif des
chiliens en faveur d'un changement de
constitution
ce référendum n'est pas la fin c'est le
début d'un chemin que nous devons tous
parcourir ensemble pour nous mettre
d'accord sur une nouvelle constitution
pour le chili jusque là la constitution
nous a divisés
à partir d'aujourd'hui nous devons tous
collaborer pour que la nouvelle
constitution soit un cadre d'unité de
stabilité et d'avenir dans la rue des
dizaines de milliers de citoyens se sont
rassemblés pour célébrer la victoire du
oui à ce scrutin jugé historique
ce référendum était attendu par les
chiliens c'était l'une de leurs
revendications depuis que le soulèvement
populaire a commencé il ya un an un
mouvement de protestations provoquées
par les inégalités sociales dans le pays
la vérité est que tous les chiliens ont
de grandes aspirations
nous attendons beaucoup de ce changement
mais le plus important c'est la dignité
et je pense que nous avons obtenu la
dignité que nous recherchions temps
c'est le fondement c'est le fondement de
tout et nous continuerons à aller de
l'avant
nous continuerons à lutter pour sa
toujours à côté du changement de
constitution
les chiliens devaient également choisir
quelle institution rédigera le nouveau
texte
la majorité a voté pour une convention
constituante formé uniquement par des
citoyens
la nouvelle constitution sera soumise à
référendum en 2022
[Applaudissements]